hey hello everybody and welcome to
episode five of my payto playay flipping
series uh we're starting this episode
about four mil we have just bought a
brand new Bond so we have a full 14 days
and uh we're going to see how far we can
get today uh if you notice my voice is a
little bit shot I was in a music
festival and now it's really sore and my
back's sore too but uh we're just going
to put another episode out today
hopefully um yeah so let's just jump
into it
here and for the first item here we're
going to do Bow strings um we just
actually check the buying limit quickly
there so you can get 13k of them at a
time uh it has a 6 GP margin so that's
like uh 60k or
something yeah I don't know I I can't
think very well so yeah it's probably a
good amount of money there so we'll find
one more
item and next up here I think we're
going to try the banana actually um not
really sure why it has a 6gp margin on
it but uh I checked afterwards and
they're actually traded nearly as much
as I thought they were um but we'll give
this a try we'll get like 10k of them or
something and uh yeah we'll just get one
more item as well and lastly here we're
going to do the run Arrow uh has a 3gp
margin on it which is good for the price
and I think we can get like 11,000 of
these at a time um almost always have
made money on this item so there's no
point not to try it again uh but next up
I think we're going to try some brand
new items and kind of a new technique so
I'm kind of excited to try that um so I
will just buy I think the buying limit
of it at least if we can afford it
anyway and no we'll go for 10K and I
will check back some of them bought but
I'll check back when everything is
bought and
sold okay so we're back and we've sold
most of the items here the bananas
didn't work at all so we just did the
arrows and the PO strings um so in the
arrows we got a 3gp margin and 10K of
them so that's 30k pretty standard there
and the bow strings we managed to
actually get 5 GP margin and we got
about 8K of them so about 42k from those
we bought like 38 bananas so we're not
even going to bother even calculating
that it's not really worth it uh yes
we're going to try something else now I
think cuz this is just kind of slow so
we're going to try a new technique and
hopefully we can get some Bank from
that okay so what we're going to be
doing next is we're going to be buying
uh three dose potions and decanting them
into full dose potions uh it's pretty
easy to do it just requires a bit of a
different technique to check the margin
uh so what you have to start by doing is
buy and sell a three dose potion and you
just have to at least buy the four dose
potion uh which I'm doing on screen
right now and so what you have to do
basically is once you've bought and sold
the three items at least you're going to
take the four dose potion get a
calculator open and you're going to
times it by 75 or you just trying to get
the 3/4 price essentially so 932 for
some reason I don't on screen but 3/4 of
932 is uh
693 um so basically what's that that is
telling me is if I buy the potions three
do potions that they're low price which
is
635 and uh once I combine them all I'll
have a margin
of 58 per potion uh which is pretty good
actually and basically all I do is take
the 58 and times it by you can get 2,000
potions every four hours or something so
I take that and I can make over 100k
really easy sometimes you can even buy
the potions for their high price cuz
they're close and just buy them
instantly decant them and sell them for
a really good profit
um but not in this case so what we're
going to do is we're going to buy the
Super Attack potion 3es at about uh 635
I think and yes we'll get 2K of those
these will take a little while to buy
but they are pretty popular so we will
get another item to go but we'll check
back on this in a
bit okay and Next Step uh we really did
try to find another potion um but we
couldn't find one right now so we're
just going to do Z scales quickly uh has
a 2 GP margin on it which is pretty
standard uh I think we're going to cap
out to buy limit at least uh I don't
know actually has 30k so no act will
just do 20K the zver scales and uh nope
uh my brain's not functioning properly
but math is not working but uh yeah
we'll do 15K I guess and uh yeah I think
we're just going to check back when
these potions are bought and I'll show
you how I decant them actually we're
going to buy a guild plate skirt no time
waste so we will buy one for 315k and uh
yeah we'll be back in a little bit okay
so we're just quickly checking in here
um cuz we bought all the potions and I
just want to show you what I do so I
bought about 2,000 of them for
127k all you have to do is run down here
to Bob and he will decant them actual
for you into four dose potions uh so I
did have 2,3 dose potions now I have,
1500 four dose potions uh which does add
up I think so let's just check the
history here uh so we're going to sell
them for about 970 I think and um yes
we'll PLP him for 970 here and we'll
check the full amount CU I think we're
going to make 150 or 200k off of this
item um okay we're going to do 960 I
guess so yeah we are going to be selling
them for
1,438 K and we bought him for
1,269 um so that is 180k about again
Mass not so great right now but yeah I
think between 150 and 200k easily and
that was really quick okay so the
potions have fully sold really took only
20 30 minutes to sell um we also did a
Zoro scale flip in there as well um so
we'll start with the potions because
that's the most important there you can
see right there those are the the flip
even though it's two different types of
potions they were decanted instantly and
we made 168k on that probably under an
hour so that was really effective these
are scales we got four GP margin on and
um 15K of those makes 60k profit there
um so I think we're going to go ahead
and do these potions a bunch more
because they are working super well okay
so we're going to do the magic potion
I'll show you one more time how you do
this so we buy the magic potion three
three dose you can do it with other
potions but it's more effective with the
three dose it seems and we resell right
here just to see the margin of that and
then we are going to buy the four dose
potion and we'll just max that out and
get that right
away okay didn't buy that's actually
good uh so I actually didn't buy for
that so we'll have to put in actually a
higher price here uh which means the
margin should be pretty good because I
think I bought the three do potion for
like 3 or 400 okay so we bought for 638
so we'll open up the history here get a
calculator open so what you take is the
four dose potion which is 638 we bought
it for and we're going to times it by 75
so that is the relative margin to the
the three dose potion and then we
basically take it off like regular
margin you just minus it and we times it
by 2,000 and it looks like we can make
250k off this item which is really good
especially since it's very
inexpensive um so yeah you can see right
there there's a huge margin on it you
just have to multiply it down to
3/4 just to get or El the margin will be
totally out of whack CU it's not
accurate so we're going to put in for
actually the high price because it was
so and look at that instantly bought all
of them except where we hit the buy
limit um but yeah so we instantly bought
them for the high price and even at the
high price we're still going to make two
or 300K so this is really good so we're
going to go decant these bam got 1,500
four foros
Potions all we have to do is basically
run back in we've basically skipped one
of the entire steps of flipping so just
to see there we bought all of them for
707k
um so now after all we've done is
decanted them it took literally 30
seconds um we're just going to plop them
in there we can find the actual right
one there and we're going to sell them
for
637k and uh we will go get one more of
these potions on the go as well okay so
we're actually going to try flipping
this ranging potion to not even sure if
we're going to combine it just has a
1,000 GP margin so even if we don't
combine it um we'll still get a huge
margin on it so we're just kind of
cheeky going try to buy some of these uh
we'll just do a couple hundred cuz they
only have a couple thousand traded every
day so we'll do 500 and we'll find one
more item to do as well so actually
we're just going to get rid of the offer
we had for the plate legs and we'll just
put Z skilles in here as well um we're
just going to buy them in the background
you can see uh they bought for 164 and I
think we sld them for two or three GP
margin or something uh but the guilded
plate skirt we were buying just was not
happening so actually has a 4 GP margin
I think so that's pretty good uh we'll
go ahead and buy I think 15,000 we want
to leave enough money to buy one more
potion item um we definitely Dr enough
toit to buy them I think we're going to
do 15K um but that's still actually
pretty decent at a 4 GP margin that's
another 60k uh pretty easy I get nice
fallback
item okay so next up we're going to do
the combat potion now I've almost never
seen these before only reason I found it
is because I Ty potion into the search
bar uh but you can see there pretty
decent so again we're the mult mly 3116
by 75 uh gives us 237 and we just minus
off the we'll probably just do the Buy
price cuz it's so close and 34 GP times
2,000 that's like 70 Kish uh which is
pretty good for how cheap the item is
and yeah so we I think we're going to do
this item so we'll go by uh 2,000 again
which is the buying limit worth of the
item and we're going to do 205 and uh we
will check back when at least we've sold
the magic
potions okay so we're just checking back
in CU some things are kind of stagnating
here um these zaro scales they drop back
down so we just sold them exactly for
what we bought them for so no profit
there no loss either uh as I kind of
expected these combat potions are just
not really buying not many people
actually use I don't know who actually
uses these um but either way we're just
going to reset a couple offers here so
we went ahead and decanted them anyway
since we're not going to buy anymore um
we probably won't make very much on this
item but you can see right there we
bought them for well 13k and we'll put
them in for the high price now uh which
is just about
390k uh so I mean in theory would have
made ton of item we got 7K and only we
only bought 50 of the item um but
whatever we will take what we can get uh
same thing with ranging potion I'm not
actually sure if we're going to combine
them um but we will check we bomb for
1,000 each and um yeah so we can we
could still flip these just regularly
for about a 900 GP profit or so um which
is what we might end up doing but I
think we're going to check the four dose
potion as well to see if we should
actually be decanting these as well
because uh ranging potion four doses
will sell much quicker than the twoos
potion okay so uh we bought a four do
range potion for about 3K so we ended up
decanting uh the potions anyway uh this
will just let us sell these off much
quicker uh cuz otherwise it going to
take quite a while um so we're going to
sell them for about the 3K mark and um
we're actually still going to make 30k
off the item so even though it doesn't
seem very good it actually is working
out quite well and lastly here we're
going to do the energy potion actually
uh I think I had about the after
calculations about 60 GP margin uh we
wouldn't calculate everything here so
we're going to buy them for about
3.96 um we're going to sleep so we're
going to try buy 6K of them so hopefully
overnight we can buy all of them because
there's a 4our I think for each two ,000
uh so hopefully if I sleep for 12 hours
we should be good okay so everything's
sold uh this is a little rather
confusing so we'll try to explain this
um so we've sold the three types of
potions um for a decent profit um we'll
start with uh let's just do the magic
potions so we actually had to lower the
margin uh we stld them in two little
groups here you can see but uh in total
we still got 93 GP margin in average in
2,000 those will make 186k profit which
is which is awesome the ranging potions
we decanted in total we got a 500 GP
margin on each one uh we only got 33 of
those but that still left us with 16k
profit and the combat potions we got a
86 GP margin and uh we got 49 of those
which gave us uh about 4K profit so not
too good but uh yeah let's go ahead and
decant these potions okay so we have
decanted the potions into four do
potions so we have four 500 foros
potions now uh we actually to go on my
other account to check the margin
because I hit the buying limit again uh
but right now the high price is 588 so
we'll plop that in there and um just
yeah we should be making almost 500k off
that but we will check back when they've
sold uh but for now we'll get one more
item and last up here I think we're just
going to do the Rune arrows we didn't
quite have enough money to do some of
the other potions um but you can see the
Rune Arrow still have a 5 GP margin on
them which is pretty nice and uh this
time we can actually hit the buying
limit so we'll buy I think 11,000 of
these and uh yeah we'll check back when
we've sold everything cuz the potions
will take a
while okay so everything's sold and I
think we're going to end the episode
here uh so just to calculate the last
bit profit we got here so on the energy
potions we got a 35 GP margin uh times
4500 of them gives us about
158k on the arrows we got effectively a
4 4.3 GP margin because we actually sold
them in two different batches uh but
that gave us about 32k profit there as
well um so after everything said and
done we'll sell off all this crap in our
inventory we'll have about 4.7 mil and
we started about 4 mil so we got about 7
800k in this episode I'm very excited
for this technique because we just did a
couple of the flips we made 100K on each
one easily pretty well really quick all
of this was done in about a day um but
there's lots of content so I'm going to
split it up so hope you guys enjoyed uh
if you liked it uh don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and I will see you
guys in episode 6
[Music]